[Music]
greetings to all welcome to another
enlightening video on organic farming
practices we're excited that you're here
here with us as we explore the
captivating world of guava cultivation
guava is not only a widely grown fruit
but also cherished for its nutritional
value and sweet taste this video will
provide you with a comprehensive look at
how guavas are meticulously cultivated
to ensure top-notch
[Music]
quality Our Journey Begins at the guava
sprouts garden in changua County Taiwan
where the initial stages of guava
cultivation
occur the process starts by selecting
robust guava Sprouts which are then
carefully planted to ensure they are
firmly rooted in the soil a crucial step
for their early growth and development
once the Sprouts reach about 1 month old
they are ready to be transplanted into
Farm Fields where the real work
starts each Sprout is planted with
Precision maintaining a recommended
spacing of 1 to 1.5 M between trees this
spacing is vital as it allows each tree
ample room to grow and access necessary
nutrients without competing with
neighboring
[Music]
trees after planting the guava trees
receive water through a drip irrigation
system which ensures that each tree gets
an adequate amount of water delivered
directly to its roots this efficient
method conserves water while providing
essential hydration for growth water for
irrigation comes from nearby pumps and
undergos filtration before use to remove
impurities that could harm the plants
nutrients may also be added to support
healthy tree development
as the guava trees mature regular
maintenance like trimming is required
particularly when they reach around 4
months old to promote better growth by
focusing nutrients on fruit development
rather than excess foliage trimming also
enhances air circulation within the tree
reducing disease risk and encouraging
healthier growth additionally grass
around the trees is regularly removed to
prevent nutrient competition and keep
the plant Plantation clean and pest
[Music]
free one critical stage in guava
cultivation is preparing for fruiting
when Farmers start wrapping individual
guavas on each branch after cutting
Branch tops to direct nutrients towards
fruit production ensuring large sweet
fruits characteristic of highquality
pearl quavas interestingly only one
fruit per branch is allowed following a
selective process common in Japan known
for yielding superior quality
fruits the wrapped fruits are protected
from Birds insects rain and excessive
sun exposure using nylon bags that
create a controlled environment for
consistent highquality product
development over approximately 1.5
months until ripening especially crucial
during rainy Summers when unwrapped
fruits can easily
[Music]
[Applause]
perish while waiting for ripening
branches undergo periodic pruning
maintaining tree Health promoting better
yield and focusing nutrients on
developing fruits approaching Harvest
sweetness is checked ensuring Readiness
using specific techniques guaranteeing
only the sweetest and most mature are
harvested meeting consumer taste and
texture expectations once the desired
sweetness is achieved the anticipated
Harvest is conducted carefully avoiding
damage scissors are used to cut placing
gently in trays preventing bruising post
Harvest stems are removed followed by
thorough washing to clean and remove
residues accumulated during growing the
fruits are then neatly arranged in trays
and wrapped with shock absorbing foam
protecting them during transportation to
reach the market in perfect
condition finally they are packaged
loaded onto trucks transported to
distribution centers at various
locations and sold to Consumers marking
the end of the journey from Farm to
Market enjoy by pe enjoyed people
appreciating their sweet delicious
flavor
[Music]
we will take you next into taiwan's
bustling streets witnessing impressive
guava cutting skills a true art form in
Taiwanese street food culture watching
talented vendors skillfully cut and peel
fresh guava was transforming them into
bite-sized pieces ready to serve eager
customers traditional techniques
highlight unique preparation and
presentation whether you're a food
Enthusiast or curious about street food
globally this demonstration is sure to
Captivate and Inspire don't miss this
fascinating glimpse into a vibrant scene
[Music]
thank you for watching the video on
organic guava cultivation technology we
hope you found an informative and
enjoyed learning about the process of
farming and harvesting stay tuned for
more videos on practices and techniques
until then goodbye and see you next time
don't forget to like And subscribe to
the channel channel for more exciting
documentaries thank you for watching and
see you next time
[Music]